welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and the trailer
for shazam fury of the gods just dropped
at comic con the shazamalee is back baby
so today i'm breaking down this new
footage frame by frame to cover every
detail you might have missed the trailer
opens with eminem's song business from
his fourth studio album the eminem show
aka the album that i used to play to
make my mom angry in 2002. fun fact we
only get some lyrics from the chorus of
business in the trailer but the full
song makes multiple references to dc's
batman and robin and although business
never had a music video attached to it
eminem repurposed the superhero imagery
in its lyrics to create the comic book
style video for without me which
features marshall mathers as the boy
wonder shazam reclines on a couch in a
doctor's office lamenting his ineptitude
and inexperience as a superhero in
comparison to other dc greats the flash
aquaman and batman as he talks about
these heroes strengths we see footage
from aquaman in the justice league these
shots appear to be from zack snyder's
justice league cut and not the 2017
whedon release some folks believe that
this is an indication that warner
brothers is making the snyder cut dceu
cannon but for now i'd err on the side
of assuming that these cutaways are
purely visual aids for the trailer
shazam shoots through the atmosphere
with impressive speed and control
showing us that billy batson has honed
his powers quite a bit since the last
time we saw him in the 2018 film despite
gaining confidence and skills however
billy still has a lot to learn when it
comes to mastering shazam's powers when
he crashes you'll notice that the
buildings are being manipulated in a
similar way seen in a shot later on in
the trailer when freddy cringes at the
sight of his friend getting t-boned
mid-air he's wearing a batman and robin
t-shirt with pictures of a realistic bat
next to a realistic robin as the camera
slowly reveals more of shazam's new suit
we can see that it's definitely an
upgrade from his costume in the last
movie where his first suit was more of a
classic comic accurate version this one
is like 200 less dorky while he
confesses his origin story to his doctor
we flash back to scenes from the first
movie when billy first gained his new
powers back at the group home darla
eugene pedro freddy mary and billy are
gearing up to fight crime when they're
stopped and questioned by their foster
parents victor and rosa vazquez a few
t-shirts here might catch your eye billy
is wearing goonies merch back during the
press interviews for the first shazam
zachary levi fondly compared his movie
with spielberg's 1985 classic seeing the
goonies referenced in fury of the gods
might reflect that this outing will lean
further into the shazam family being a
band of child adventurers on a quest to
protect their home freddy's shirt sports
the symbol of the white tree of gondor
from lord of the rings this tree
symbolizes hope and the renewal of life
and even though freddie is more of billy
samwise than an aragorn this optimistic
pop culture reference is the perfect
encapsulation of the character then we
have gamer boy eugene who is wearing an
iconoclast shirt featuring robin the
silent protagonist of the 2018 game like
robin eugene has an affinity towards
technology also iconoclasts was
developed by director david f sandberg's
brother while billy's voice over
explains that everyone in the shazam ali
is now off doing their own things we see
the grown-up superhero versions of these
characters as they land on
philadelphia's benjamin franklin bridge
their suits like shazams have also been
upgraded since the last time we saw them
and this time mary aka actor grace
caroline curry doesn't transform into
actor michelle bort in this movie she's
playing herself as an adult hero because
she and the rest of the actors have all
grown since they filmed the first shazam
it turns out that shazam isn't pouring
his heart out to a therapist he's
actually at the office of an extremely
confused pediatrician who clearly didn't
specialize in children being trapped
inside zachary levi's muscular body
during med school this doctor's office
is full of easter eggs in the play area
we see three wonder woman dolls a batman
doll a flash doll a batman action figure
and two bears dressed as robin and green
lantern the abc wallpaper features three
characters from within the dceu and dc
comics k for caroquan an ancient sea
monster from aquaman comics s for starro
the giant starfish kaiju that fought
james guns the suicide squad and t for
titiano's super ape a gigantic ape with
evil kryptonite powers from superman
comics returning for her third debut in
the dceu the doll from annabelle can
also be seen chillin at the
pediatricians david f sandberg the
director of both shazam movies was also
the director of annabelle creation you
can spot the creepy doll at the
beginning of the first movie inside of
the pawn shop before billy locks the two
cops inside likewise james wan the
writer of aquaman worked as a producer
on the conjuring 2 annabelle and
annabelle creation you can also see that
scary little freak right where she
belongs in a pile of trash at the bottom
of the ocean in aquaman next we see this
large palatial structure beneath the
swirling looming sky that actually kind
of reminds me of mount olympus from
greek mythology i think that this shot
definitely takes place in the realm of
the gods a location that producer peter
saffron mentioned back in a teaser from
2021. he said quote we go from athens to
philadelphia we go from the rock of
eternity to the library of eternity to
the realm of the gods i think that this
structure could be home to the film's
antagonists the daughters of atlas in
the same way that mount olympus was home
to zeus and the other gods and
mythological tales as we learned in the
first film the rock of eternity is the
wizard's lair so my next logical guess
is that this room that appears towards
the end of the trailer is the library of
eternity in athens greece we briefly see
the acropolis atop the hill of the muses
before being taken inside a local museum
where the daughters of atlas hespera and
calypso are removing their traditional
greek battle helmets in preparation for
a heist played by dame helen miriam and
lucy liu hespera and calypso's
characters are unique to fury of the
gods they don't appear in dc comics
instead both are inspired by nymphs from
greek mythology hespera is based on the
hesperides three nymphs of dawn and dusk
tasked with protecting the golden apple
tree in harrah's garden interestingly in
the teaser from 2021 we see hespera
clutching a monotone black apple which
could be a nod to the fact that the gods
and their gardens have lost their magic
to the shazamily calypso was influenced
by calypso the nymph most notable for
trapping odysseus on her island agaija
for seven years in homer's the odyssey
both are daughters of the titan atlas a
pre-olympian god cursed to hold the
heavens on his shoulders for eternity as
they prepare to steal the staff that
shazam broke in half in the first movie
you can see a sculpture of atlas holding
the globe in the background atlas does
appear as a character in dc comics and
was even one of shazam's antagonists and
the infected king shazam but based on
what we know about fury of the gods
we're gonna see more mythology the comic
book lore from the villains in this film
during a panel at comic con rachel
zegler confirmed that her character
would be the third daughter of atlas and
thea oddly enough anthea isn't one of
atlas's daughters in greek mythology nor
does she appear anywhere in dc comics
she's technically a thespian princess
daughter of king thespias and megameen
mother to one of heracles children when
hespera first removes her helmet is it
just me or does her right eye seem a lot
brighter blue than her left when the eye
of sins flew into dr savannah's face
hole in the last movie his right eye
also glowed like an evil lava lamp when
his sparrow reaches out and grasps the
broken staff a lightning bolt seemingly
ignites beneath her skin illuminating
her eyes and reawakening the staff's
magic in spite of shazam's previous
efforts to destroy it the next time we
see the staff calypso is holding it
glowing and intact next to her sisters
notice that anthea is standing apart
from her sisters another hint that the
third daughter of atlas might be more
sympathetic towards humanity than
hespera and calypso freddie's also
present here and is seen with anthea
quite a lot in this trailer leading me
to believe that this young goddess might
fall in love with humanity through a
romance with freddy they also hold hands
here while being attacked by the dragon
later on in the trailer another shot
later on has anthea blasted backwards by
a beam of blue lightning this must have
come from the staff because shazam's
lightning is white meaning it's likely
that her sisters will turn on her here
hesphera tells us that children stole
power from all of the gods seemingly
referring to when billy decided to share
shazam's powers with his foster siblings
in 1940s whiz comics number two each of
the powers that the wizard shazam
bestows on billy batson are drawn from
seven greek gods and heroes s for
solomon's wisdom h for hercules strength
a for atlas's stamina z for zeus's power
a for achilles courage and m for mercury
speed perhaps in fury of the gods it'll
turn out that billy stole or diluted
these god's powers when he transferred
part of his magic to darla eugene pedro
freddy and mary this is also a nod to
the myth of prometheus in which the
titan prometheus stole fire from the
gods and gave it to humanity zeus
punished prometheus by chaining him to a
rock and sending an eagle to peck at his
liver for eternity and it seems that the
daughters of atlas are the eagles to
billy's liver in this situation my
personal favorite part of the trailer
was shazam's shout out to the fast and
the furious franchise mostly because i
spent the entire pandemic making dominic
toretto my whole personality but also
because of the triple decker easter egg
we get out of this one tiny little
moment i've seen all of the fast and the
furious movies lady it's all about
family not only does shazam try to use a
reference to the fast family to signal
his siblings to attack hespera player
one hespera aka dame helen mirren
herself plays queenie shaw and fate of
the furious hobbs and shaw fast and
furious 9 and the upcoming fast x layer
2 the wizard is played by jimin hansu
who also played mosai jakande in furious
7. and layer 3. the most beautiful layer
of all is that fury of the gods writer
chris morgan also wrote the majority of
the fast saga something tells me that
billy is gonna freak when he sees that
his arch nemesis black adam is played by
the friggin rock as the shazoomers march
down the neighborhood and transform into
their alter egos you can see the words
torpa and unidoll painted on a fence
these are both swedish schools that
director david f sandberg attended with
torpa being the one where he met his
wife lota lotha plays a scientist in the
first shazam and has revealed on
instagram that she'll have another small
role in this film calypso causes large
root-like masses to grow out of citizen
bank park home of the philadelphia
phillies as the wizard tells the
shazamily that the world will not
survive this the vines can be seen
spreading up buildings in the city and
destroying the stadium really pulling
out of bane's playbook aren't you
calypso despite mary studying the
daughters of atlas's powers in their
lair aka the rock of eternity where the
wizard initially imprisoned the seven
deadly sins the looks on their faces
tell me that these kids aren't ready to
face the horrifying array of mythical
beasts that await them not only does a
huge dragon crash land in the stadium
peter saffron also stated that we'll be
seeing several other magic monsters and
fury of the gods such as minotaurs
harpies manticores and even mega
unicorns as seen towards the end of the
trailer and it can't be a coincidence
that those matte black unicorns are the
same shade as hespera's apple when
anthea ignites the symbols on her hands
they form three swirling circles on her
palms that begin to spin along with the
platform that she hyspera calypso and
freddie are standing on in the final
moment of the trailer shazam throws a
truck at the dragon in the background
there's a marquee that reads volchy an
homage to lucio fultry the godfather of
gore who was like sandberg a horror
director if you check out shazam's suit
here however most of the left side has
been burned to a crisp which appears to
have happened when his suit caught on
fire in a scene shown at the beginning
of the trailer seeing as this dragon
breathes blue flames i wouldn't be
surprised if in the final cut the flames
that sin shazam are blue and mystical
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitney puppy follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
announce with everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you